Hello Freak bitches.
How'd you get so well,
how did you get the Alex Jones wanted to be nine 11 nine one one I had a plan it
out so I had to,
we had to do,
I had a fit some podcasts in,
I had to do like extra ones the week before just so I could get to number nine
11 with Alex,
right,
wasn't it?
That sounds like a long,
see pat him on earlier and I would have definitely had them on again for nine 11
but having one the first time for nine 11 and to this day,
that's our biggest podcasts by really by maybe 5 million downloads.
Fuck yeah,
but here's the conspiracy,
right?
Is that right?
Am I saying correctly?
What is the actual number?
Probably 16 now.
I didn't check in the last two or three days,
but okay,
so it's 16 million dot.
Here's what's crazy.
It never charted on iTunes.
The iTunes charts magically went down while the Alex Jones podcast was in the
queue and they stayed down for over a week.
Conspiracy theory and then when it came back up podcasts that got way less
downloads than Alex's.
We're re we're rated much higher than his and they had happened before and
afterwards.
I do remember kids was the only podcast that was left out of the ratings loop,
like for sure it would have been the number one podcast in the country.
It was the number one podcast we did by a mile and I've had the number one
podcast before.
It's like the number one podcast episode that was more than 5 million downloads
more than any other podcasts I had before.
So it's should for sure probably would have been number one if it wasn't a lot
of downloads unless they had like one of those serial episodes or something that
came out that week.
So there you go.
And that's,
it's very likely that someone's trying to hold Alex Jones back and that's just
stokes his fucking fight.
They don't understand this.
The Streisand effect can stoke the fire of Alex Jones.
Even Megan Kelly's fuck now her show's going down the toilet.
It can happen in the aftermath.
She,
here's the,
here's the problem is a problem.
Megan Kelly was a Fox News person.
She left Fox News to go to NBC.
NBC is thought of as CNBC,
which is thought of as fake news by these right wing Trump.
Trump bands,
what would you call him?
Trump Trumpers.
So as soon as she goes over there,
they're not going to listen to her.
And then to the liberals,
she's Fox News,
right?
So they're not interested in either.
And then she does this podcast with Alex Jones or this interview rather with
Alex Jones and the interview with Alex Jones.
She says,
I'm not going to paint you out as a monster.
I'm going to give you a fair,
like she's saying all these things,
like she's going to throw softballs as way.
I want people to get to know you.
And he releases all that and he's like,
Hey,
this is that person.
And then the ratings just keep cutting,
right?
Like,
but famous but not like Tom Cruise fairness.
Right.
Tom Cruise,
like connected with that person.
I can't,
it would make it a better story if I hadn't remembered who it was.
But it was somebody like that,
like your level or like or,
or like a mark Duplass or you know what I'm saying?
Like I don't know who mark the plaza's.
Well he's the guy at your level.
No,
no,
he's,
I know he is the duplos.
She knows who everybody is.
I don't know who the deposit there,
ed there,
they're made the show togetherness on Hbo.
My point isn't about the Duplass brothers is like,
they were just like semi famous,
not like
Tom Cruise cruise.
Got It.
So yeah,
so horny,
she wants to get to the fight.
So you see he got invited to a Superbowl party at this person's house.
Right.
I could imagine if Tom Cruise is coming to your house for the Super Super Bowl
super bowl party,
he was like,
oh whoa asking Tom Cruise.
And he says yes.
I like honey,
you said yes.
What do we do?
Right?
And the Mediterranean Tom Cruise be like,
I think I will be among the humans today.
So Tom Cruise,
it barely shows up with a brand new,
like clearly fresh football,
but his assistant like you know,
he's like tossing like a literal brand new football in the air.
Right.
And they're all talking about marriage at some point in the day and goes,
do you know what the best part of being married is though?
Right.
It's fucking your wife,
am I right?
You just fuck your wife and everybody's like felt like tumbleweeds are all the
parts sort of like a robot,
like an alien visiting us.
Yeah.
He must be amazing to hang out with.
I would love to hang out with him.
Fucking your wife.
Right?
I mean when you're that famous,
your work ethic,
it's like you just devote everything to that I think because like I have my,
my agents were like,
they know that the agents who are Tom Cruise,
they didn't,
they said Tom Cruise always gets back within an hour when we send a script,
cause I like keep a script for like three weeks and then by the time I read it,
the parts being gassed.
Is it Tom Cruise?
We'll read a script and an hour and get back to them and either like it or not
like it.
Like he's just like on the ball.
He's,
yeah,
he's like,
he's trying to win.
He's won and it's an inhuman instinct because our human instinct is to just
atrophy in a way.
I mean you have to kind of fight it,
but easy to be lazy.
I'm to procrastinate.
It's definitely easy to be lazy,
but it's not.
If you're going to be Tom cruise really have to be on the ball.
There's no other way.
It doesn't just time job.
That's not just what's going on and was just some weird alien sort of behavior
patterns that we don't recognize as being normal.
Like when he jumped up on Oprah's couch,
it's like I'm in love,
I'm in love,
and it was like,
what the fuck is going on here?
I,
it's like it's a person.
No,
it's like a person who doesn't understand French,
but you're speaking French to a French person who saying all the right words,
like what the fuck is wrong?
It seems like every choice he makes outside of acting is based on what he's
assuming normal human beings think is the normal behavior.
Right?
So it goes,
Ooh,
love is when you jump on a couch or go,
I love her,
which is informed by movies really.
Right?
Like that's more movie like,
right.
That's like John Cusak and say anything like,
oh,
that's what love looks like.
It's not,
you know,
or telling a bunch of the fellows in Oregon to have sex talk with the fellows.
Oh,
it's a wild look to fuck my wife.
Huh?
The friction of her vagina makes me just sploosh how right guys?
And everyone's like
everyone like,
oh,
we're sick of fucking,
do you remember when people were wearing those,
a holograms attached to a rubber band around their wrist?
And,
uh,
do you remember these stupid fucking things?
Do you remember him?
Jamie?
You remember?
Right?
I think Gwyneth Paltrow has got in trouble for selling them on her.
Like,
well,
damn fucking bitch.
Same thing.
No offense.
But I might've,
I might've said some mean things about,
it's been a couple of things about her lately and her fucking nutty website.
She takes,
she,
you're supposed to wear like a rock inside your vagina.
Isn't that one of those things?
I call them pussy rocks.
Yeah.
Pussy rocks are hilarious.
I guess it would be like strengthen you
if you want to strengthen it.
Just two key goals around a dick.
That's my,
that's my method.
Works out.
Maybe if it can't be a dick or a rocks.
Good way to go.
Gwyneth Paltrow wants to heal you with magic stickers.
Jesus Christ.
She needs getting paid though.
I'll tell you that.
There's a lot of dummies out there that are sought momming all the way to the
ATM machine.
She is proof that bullshit sells way better than science.
I'm,
I do not have her,
her salary.
Oh wait a minute.
You can rebalance the energy frequency.
I didn't know that.
Hold on a second.
She's discovered something about stickers.
Do.
If you take these stickers,
if they're made with the right material,
you just stick them on your body in the right places.
And they in quotes rebalance the energy frequency in our bodies are made out of
a NASA space suit material.
And NASA said it was a load of bs,
but hold on a second.
I don't think that NASA is right.
Bunch of movies.
Hold on cause he'll just stop.
Stop.
School science says Gwyneth Paltrow's goop website,
a lifestyle business lifestyle which sells all things with advertise.
These stickers are using NASA space suit material,
which presumably was the source of their magic healing properties.
Jesus fucking Christ.
She's special stickers and not made.
This is what NASA says.
They're not made of space suit material,
not that space.
New suit material.
It has healing properties.
The first place it doesn't,
but the quote from the foreign NASA scientist,
Mark Shel Shel Ham Shell Shell Hummer Shelmar Shelmar sums it up.
Uh,
he goes,
wow,
what a load of bs this is or that.
Yeah,
okay.
She's obviously goop,
quickly updated its site.
Now,
it doesn't claim anything about NASA space suits and stickers,
but it didn't dial back end in the magical healing claims.
Here's what coops has now in an article called wearable stickers that promote
healing in parentheses.
Really,
you fuck human bodies operate at an ideal energetic frequency,
but everyday stresses and anxiety.
You're giving me stress.
You Bitch,
you can throw off our internal balance,
depleting our energy reserves and weakening our immune system.
I'm fucking imagine thinking that you could put a sticker on you and it's going
to heal you.
Body vibe stickers.
Oh my God.
They're called body vibes coming pre pre-pro.
They come preprogrammed.
Oh fuck the programming.
I didn't know that to an ideal frequency,
allowing them to target imbalances.
You motherfucker,
you fucking crook.
Don't you have enough money,
bitch it Jesus Christ.
Currently,
the residuals on the iron man movies just weren't enough for her.
God Damn.
60 bucks for a 10 pound.
Holy Shit.
All right.
Yeah.